we're about halfway through the
expedition now for the last two or three
weeks Basecamp has literally been
growing in population
it's also been shrinking or melting
we're actually camping on a glacier it's
covered with rock and rubble and
throughout the weeks now the glacier is
slowly melting around us you can
actually see for example by looking at
your own tent how it's creating a shaded
platform and everything around it is
melting base camp is really filling out
there's 27 expeditions here right now
it's an international city where you get
a really colorful cast of characters
from all over the world we have two
programs the one group is his group is
Rocha Chow I'm smaller from Italy it's
the first time for me here this camp and
I will try to last year when I was here
climbing I met pratima who's one of the
most experienced Sherpa in the Khumbu
for sure and his nephew Dallas Stevens
and they were starting this project of
collecting garbage and it's pretty
amazing to see what it's turning into
this year I represent a new generation
of shippers we are more exposed to the
world a lot of us are more educated than
previous generation this year I've
invited all the Sherpas at base camp to
contribute with the cash-for-trash
project and every kilo of garbage they
bring here I give them a hundred rupees
this is our fifth day we've collected
two thousand kilograms of garbage so far
we're very optimistic and it's going to
be quite a big success it's surprising
to a lot of people that base camp isn't
actually just a garbage dump it's
relatively clean everybody works really
hard to clean up the garbage that we
bring in were accountable for bringing
out that weight at the end of the trip I
request to everybody to respect to the
nature and try to help to click wherever
we go
not only the Samata but there are all
the Himalaya vents
[Music]